This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We start today with an account of two communities. One is liberal, the other conservative. I want you to guess which is which. The schools would stress patriotism and respect, and it would be a very rules-based educational system. The houses would be fairly similar. The lawns would be very nicely kept
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天我们先来聊两个社区的故事。一个是自由派的，另一个是保守派的。我想让你猜猜哪个是哪个。学校会强调爱国主义和尊严，这将是一个非常注重规则的教育系统。房屋会相当相似。草坪会打理得非常整洁
and beautifully green and moored. The town would be quiet with lots of churches. That's town one. Here's town two. The schools would be based more on experiential kinds of things rather than then wrote memory. People would prefer older houses with wooden floors rather than wall-to-wall carpeting. They would keep the yard's natural. Lots of bars and community theaters and foreign films, more of those than churches. That was easy, right? Conservatives like order, liberals embrace ambiguity. Now, you may be rolling your eyes or even getting angry at these stereotypes.
而且绿意盎然、修剪得很好。小镇会很安静，有很多教堂。这是第一个小镇。接下来是第二个小镇。学校将更多地基于体验式学习，而不是死记硬背。人们会更喜欢带有木地板的老房子，而不是满地铺的地毯。他们会保持庭院的自然状态。有很多酒吧、社区剧院和外国电影，这些比教堂还要多。这很简单，对吧？保守派喜欢秩序，自由派拥抱模糊性。现在，你可能会翻白眼，甚至对这些刻板印象感到生气。
But we all know there's more than a grain of truth to them. So how did these two towns, which our guests today refers to as liberalville and conservaton, get this way? When most of us think about how we came to our political views, we tend to have a straight forward explanation. We use our upbringing and life experiences as the basis for our political beliefs. We imagine that our parents, teachers, and friends shape our views on everything from taxes and the
但我们都知道，这些说法并非空穴来风。那么，我们的今天的嘉宾称之为“自由村”和“保守镇”这两个小镇，是怎么变成这样的呢？当大多数人思考我们的政治观点是如何形成的时，我们往往会有一个直截了当的解释。我们以自己的成长经历和生活经验作为政治信仰的基础。我们想象着我们的父母、老师和朋友塑造了我们对从税收、
economy to immigration and national security. But what if I told you there is something deeper to those attitudes? Drives that shape the music we listen to, the food we eat, the politicians we elect. This week on Hidden Brain, how the partisan divide in our country might arise not just from our upbringing and lived experiences, but from biology. On a regular basis, right before an election, someone will share an article with me about how science proves that the brains of liberals are stunted. Or a post on Twitter will say, Republicans are less intelligent than Democrats. These claims obscure something far more interesting and far more accurate.
经济到移民和国家安全等一切事物的看法。但如果我告诉你，这些态度背后还有更深层次的东西呢？那些塑造了我们听的音乐、吃的食物、选举的政客的驱动力。本周的《隐藏大脑》节目将探讨：我们国家的党派分歧，可能不仅仅源于我们的成长背景和生活经历，还源于生物学。在选举前的常规日子里，经常有人跟我分享一篇文章，说科学证明自由派的大脑发育不全。或者推特上会有一条帖子说，共和党人不如民主党人聪明。这些说法掩盖了一些更有趣、也准确得多事实。
There are genuine psychological differences between liberals and conservatives. Understanding these differences can give us fresh insight into our political conflicts. John Hibbing is a political scientist at the University of Nebraska-Lincoln. He has spent many years studying the psychological and neurological differences between liberals and conservatives. He is co-author of the book, predisposed, liberals, conservatives, and the biology of political differences. John, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shanakaar. Pleasure to be with you. When most of us think about how we came to our political views, John, we have a relatively
自由派和保守派之间确实存在心理差异。理解这些差异可以为我们理解政治冲突提供新的视角。约翰·希宾是内布拉斯加大学林肯分校的政治学教授。他多年来一直致力于研究自由派和保守派在心理和神经学上的差异。他是《天生倾向：自由派、保守派与政治分歧的生物学》一书的合著者。约翰，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴能来到这里。约翰，当大多数人思考我们的政治观点是如何形成的时，我们有一个相对
straightforward explanation that has to do with our upbringing and background. How does that theory go? Well, whenever I ask my students where their political views come from, the first thing I say is their parents. And I think we have this sense that those views that our parents have passed along are supplemented by those, you know, from a clergy member or a trusted relative, a close friend. But we sort those through our own view of the world and we come to a very rational understanding of the world and an understanding of what social policies are best to make the world better. are best to make the world better. So we're going to look in depth at some of the psychological and brain differences that do exist between liberals and conservatives, but I want to start by looking at how differences
直截了当的解释，这与我们的成长经历和背景有关。这个理论是怎么说的呢？嗯，每当我问学生他们的政治观点来自哪里时，他们首先想到的就是父母。我想我们有一种感觉，父母传给我们的这些观点，会得到神职人员、受信赖的亲戚或亲密朋友的补充。但我们会通过自己的世界观去筛选这些观点，从而对世界产生一种非常理性的理解，并理解什么样的社会政策才能让世界变得更好。才能让世界变得更好。因此，我们将深入探讨自由派和保守派之间确实存在的某些心理和大脑差异，但我想首先来看看
between partisans are not limited to politics. These differences show up in many domains that have nothing to do with politics. Republican President George H.W. Bush once spoke about an issue that had bothered him for many years. us about liberals and conservatives. Well, we tend to see that there are differences in taste. Conservatives do like meat potatoes more, liberals are more likely to prefer ethnic food. So you see that and that we think is part of a deeper pattern of conservatives are a little bit fond of kind of predictability, of standard kinds of things, and liberals are a little bit more willing to experiment in this come through and food taste in a variety of other things. Here's another example.
党派之间的差异并不局限于政治。这些差异表现在许多与政治毫无关系的领域。共和党总统老布什曾谈到一个困扰他多年的问题。关于自由派和保守派，能给我们讲讲吗？嗯，我们往往会看到他们的品味有所不同。保守派更喜欢土豆炖肉，而自由派更有可能偏爱异国美食。所以你会看到这一点，我们认为这反映了更深层的规律：保守派稍微喜欢一点可预测性、标准化的事物，而自由派则更愿意尝试新事物，这一点体现在食物口味以及各种其他事情上。这里有另一个例子。
Researchers once went into the living spaces of people, offices, and dorm rooms, and they recorded the items that they saw. What was different about the living and work spaces of liberals and conservatives? Well, conservatives tended to have lots of things like sports, memorabilia, whereas liberals tended to have more experiential things, lots of books, lots of CDs, especially diverse CDs, whereas conservatives were more likely to have things that organized their lives, calendars, clothes baskets. Also, the researchers suggested the liberals' rooms were not quite as tidy tidy or as well-lighted as the conservative rooms and offices.
研究人员曾进入人们的起居空间、办公室和宿舍，并记录他们看到的物品。自由派和保守派的生活与工作空间有什么不同？嗯，保守派往往有很多诸如体育纪念品之类的小物件，而自由派往往有更多体验式的东西，比如大量的书籍、大量的CD，尤其是风格多元的CD，相比之下，保守派更有可能拥有那些让生活井井有条的物品，比如日历、洗衣篮。此外，研究人员指出，自由派的房间不如保守派的房间和办公室那么整洁或明亮。
There's even been some research looking at differences in our preferences for different kinds of pets. I understand Jonathan Height and others have explored that Liberals and Conservatives gravitated different kinds of dogs. Different kinds of dogs, it tends to be the case that conservatives prefer purebreds, and liberals will go with mixed breed dogs. There are some studies that suggest how you view pets. There isn't that much difference in how many have pets.
甚至还有一些研究探讨了我们对不同种类宠物的偏好差异。据我了解，乔纳森·海特和其他人曾对此进行过探讨，自由派和保守派倾向于不同种类的狗。不同种类的狗，情况往往是保守派更喜欢纯种狗，而自由派则会选择混血狗。有一些研究表明了你如何看待宠物。在养宠物的人数比例上，其实并没有那么大差异。
Both liberals and conservatives like to have pets at a body equal level, but they might view them somewhat differently. Liberals are a little bit more likely to view them as part of the family, rather than, you know, just a pet. So you have those kinds of very interesting things, not just in pet ownership, but kind of in orientation to the pet. The patterns that John and others have identified are more than just curious. These patterns suggest that our model of political differences is wrong in an important way. Liberals and conservatives don't just
无论是自由派还是保守派，在基本层面上都喜欢养宠物，但他们对宠物的看法可能会有所不同。自由派稍微更有可能把它们视为家庭成员，而不仅仅是“宠物”。所以你会发现这些非常有趣的事情，不仅在宠物所有权方面，还在于对待宠物的态度上。约翰和其他人发现的这些模式不仅仅是奇闻异事。这些模式表明，我们对政治分歧的固有模式在某个重要方面是错误的。自由派和保守派不仅有
have different political preferences, they have different temperaments. Conservatives don't just care about low-attacks, they also care about where the poetry rhymes. That's right. Should poetry rhyme, we also ask, are you more comfortable with novels that end with clear resolution? Those kinds of things. And, you know, you can start to see a pattern already, I think, in our discussion that it is the case that liberals are more like that is they say,
不同的政治偏好，他们还有不同的性格。保守派关心的不仅是低税收，他们还关心诗歌是否押韵。没错。诗歌是否应该押韵，我们还会问：对于以清晰结局收尾的小说，你是否会感觉更舒适？诸如此类的问题。而且，我想你在我们的讨论中已经开始看出一种规律了，那就是自由派更倾向于——也就是说他们会说：
Sure, I'm okay with free verse. Whereas conservatives say, now, you know, we really think there should be a pattern. Music should come back to a recognizable melody. Poetry should rhyme and novels should wrap up in a way that we are comfortable with. To be clear, the differences John identifies are averages. So you can certainly have a Republican who likes free verse and a Democrat who hates jazz. The point of this research isn't to stereotype liberals and conservatives, but to show that our political choices flow from deeply ingrained psychological differences. Many of us don't realize how our choices as consumers, the cars we buy, the food we eat,
当然，我能接受自由诗。而保守派则会说，不，你知道，我们真的认为应该有某种规律。音乐应该回归可识别的旋律。诗歌应该押韵，小说应该以让我们感到舒适的方式收尾。需要明确的是，约翰所指出的差异是平均值。所以你当然可以遇到一个喜欢自由诗的共和党人，或者一个讨厌爵士乐的民主党人。这项研究的重点不是给自由派和保守派贴上刻板标签，而是为了表明我们的政治选择源于根深蒂固的心理差异。我们许多人没有意识到，作为消费者，我们的选择——我们买的汽车、吃的食物、
the music we listen to, that these choices inadvertently reveal our political preferences. So I'm happy to tell people on Facebook what kind of music I listen to, but I imagine that they wouldn't be able to tell from that whether I was a Democrat or a Republican. I asked John about research that suggests you can tell whether someone's a conservative or a liberal, if you know what kind of movies they watch, what kind of food they eat, what kind of vacations they take. It's very reasonable that people would not resonate with that line of argument because to them, it's not like they say, well, you know, in order to be a good conservative, I need
听的音乐——这些选择无意中暴露了我们的政治偏好。所以我很高兴在脸书上告诉别人我听什么音乐，但我猜他们无法从这些信息中看出我是民主党人还是共和党人。我问约翰关于一项研究的看法，该研究表明，只要知道一个人看什么电影、吃什么食物、去哪里度假，就能判断他是保守派还是自由派。人们不认同这种观点是非常合理的，因为对他们来说，这并不意味着他们会说，“嗯，你知道，为了成为一个好保守派，我需要
to do this or in order to be a good liberal. So you know, they're just being themselves. And I think that's the real message here is that our political beliefs are part and parcel of our entire being. You know, it's not like they're completely separate. And it's just a natural outgrowth of these larger psychological and even physiological tendencies that we've been talking about. When we come back, the psychological traits and brain differences that shape our political
这样做”或者“为了成为一个好自由派，我需要那样做”。所以你知道，他们只是在做自己。我认为这里真正的信息是，我们的政治信仰是我们整个生命密不可分的一部分。你知道，它们并非完全孤立。这只是我们一直在谈论的这些更大规模的心理甚至生理倾向的自然产物。休息过后，我们将探讨塑造我们政治选择和偏好的心理特质与大脑差异。
choices and preferences. Stay with us. I want to start with one of the most important differences you and others have identified when it comes to politics, liberals and conservatives differ when it comes to how they see threats and danger. Here's Wayne Lapierre of the National Rifle Association. We know, in the world that surrounds us. There are terrorists and there are home invaders,
请继续关注。我想从你和他人发现的关于政治的最重要差异之一开始：在看待威胁和危险的方式上，自由派和保守派存在分歧。这是美国全国步枪协会的韦恩·拉皮埃尔。我们知道，在我们周围的世界里。有恐怖分子，有入室抢劫犯，
drug cartels, carjacquers, knockout gamers, and rapers, and haters, and campus killers, airport killers, shopping mall killers. So talk about this difference, John. When liberals hear this, what do they hear? When conservatives hear this, what do they hear? Yeah, it really is a remarkable quote. I remember John Stewart played this once on the daily show,
贩毒集团、劫车犯、连环晕倒游戏制造者、强奸犯、仇恨者、校园杀手、机场杀手、购物中心杀手。那么约翰，请谈谈这种差异。当自由派听到这些时，他们听到的是什么？当保守派听到这些时，他们听到的是什么？是的，这确实是一段引人注目的引言。我记得乔恩·斯图尔特曾在《每日秀》上播放过这段视频，
and after the clip, they shan't pan back to Stewart. What the hell you left? And he was hiding behind his desk. So you get the sense that if you listen to this very long, you're scared of everything. The message that I take from this is that you play this to liberals and they say, this guy's nuts. Others have told me he's just doing it because he makes millions
短片播放完后，镜头摇回了斯图尔特。你到底在搞什么鬼？他躲在了自己的办公桌后面。所以你会有一种感觉，如果你听这个听得太久，你会害怕一切。我从这番话中得到的讯息是，你把这个放给自由派听，他们会说，这家伙疯了。其他人告诉我，他这么做只是因为他从NRA赚了数百万美元，他自己并不真的相信这些。我认为他是相信的。这些威胁对他是非常真实的，如果我们不让那些没有这种感觉的人去理解确实有人有这种感觉，我们就无法取得任何进展。同样地，世上的韦恩·拉皮埃尔们也需要明白，对某些人来说，他们只是——他们并没有像他那样将世界视为充满威胁的，他们也不认为我们需要围绕着减轻这些威胁来构建我们的社会。所以你知道，当像乔恩·斯图尔特这样的自由派躲在办公桌后时，他部分的行为是在嘲笑韦恩·拉皮埃尔，对吧？他有点像是在说，这太荒谬了。
of dollars from the NRA and he doesn't really believe it. I think he does. These threats are very real to him and we're not going to get anywhere unless people who don't feel that way understand that some people do. Likewise, the Wayne Lopiers of the world need to understand that for some people, they just, they don't see the world as threatening as he does, and they don't think we need to build our society around mitigating those threats. So you know, when a liberal like John Stuart hides behind the desk, partly what he's doing is he's mocking Wayne Lopierry, right? He's sort of saying, this is ridiculous.
想象所有这些威胁基本上都围绕在我们身边，这简直荒谬透顶。我们生活在一个相对安全的社会里。而乔恩·斯图尔特基本上想要传达的是，你知道，你所说的话根本说不通。而你所说的话是，对你来说可能说不通，但对韦恩·拉皮埃尔来说是说得通的。没错。你知道，保守党人最喜欢对自由派说的一句话是，他们根本“不懂”，意思是，他们没有意识到这是一个危险的世界。我认为这绝对是真的。但这并不是说他们不懂，是因为他们愚钝或消息不灵通。
It's beyond ridiculous to imagine that all these threats are basically around us. We live in a relatively safe society. And basically what John Stuart is communicating is, you know, what you're saying doesn't make any sense. And what you're saying is, it might not make sense to you, but it makes sense to weigh in the peer. Exactly. You know, one of the favorite things for conservatives to say about liberals is that they just don't get it, meaning that, you know, they don't appreciate that it's a dangerous world. And I think that is absolutely true. But it's not that they don't appreciate that it's a dangerous world. And I think that is absolutely true. But it's not that they don't get it because they're being obtuse or they're not informed.
他们阅读世界上的事件，只是对这些事件的反应不同。同样地，自由派也需要认识到，虽然这看起来可能很傻，而且你对乔恩·斯图尔特的嘲笑也没错，怎么能整天提心吊胆地生活呢，等等。但对他们而言，这一切都非常真实，而一个好公民必须保持警惕，随时准备战斗，以保护自己、家人和整个社会免受这些威胁。这两组人有趣的地方在于，我们有一种非常强大的错觉，认为世界上其他人看世界的方式和我们看世界的方式是一样的。
They read about events in the world and they just don't respond to them in the same way. And likewise liberals rather need to recognize that while this may seem silly and you're right about John Stuart mocking us, how can you live your life, worried, and whatever. But to them, this is very real, and a good citizen is vigilant and is prepared to do battle, to protect himself, his family, and society from those threats. What's interesting about both groups here is that there is a very powerful illusion that we have that the rest of the world sees the world the way that we see the world.
如果他们得出了不同的结论，那一定是因为他们故意愚钝或带有某种蓄意的偏见，而不是因为人们实际上——他们可能看到了同样的世界，但他们对世界的反应实际上可能非常大相径庭。是的，我很高兴你提出这一点。心理学家谈到过“错误共识”。事实证明，如果你的最爱颜色是蓝色，你就会极大地高估人口中以蓝色为最爱颜色的人的比例。
And if they come to a different conclusion, it must be because they're being deliberately obtuse or somehow deliberately biased, as opposed to the idea that people are actually, they might be seeing the world the same way, but their reactions to the world might actually be very different. Yeah, I'm really glad you brought that up. Psychologists talk about false consensus. So it turns out that if your favorite color is blue, you grossly overstate the percent of the population whose favorite color is blue.
所以我想我们需要认识到这一点。我们曾经做过一项关于雄烯酮的研究。事实证明，由于我们的嗅觉系统结构不同，人们对它的气味反应大不闻。有些人觉得气味很好闻，闻起来有点像曲奇饼干或熏香。其他人则觉得气味难闻，闻起来像汗水甚至尿液。还有一些人根本闻不到气味。这是一种基于基因的差异，所以我们让一群研究生去闻这个。
So I think we need to recognize that. We did a study once as a substance and drostinone. It turns out that people smell it very differently, just because our olfactory systems are structured differently. Some people smell it very favorably, it smells like kind of cookies or incense. Others smell it unfavorably, it'll smell like sweat or even urine. And some don't smell it at all. And it's a genetically-based difference, so we had a bunch of our graduate students smell
我记得有个家伙，他闻了一下，觉得气味简直糟透了。而其他许多研究生并没有觉得气味那么糟糕。他坚信这是一种心理把戏，是我们试图让他说，“哦，是的，闻起来不坏。”这是那类研究之一。然而事实上，他只是不相信人们在闻这种物质时会有如此巨大的差异。我认为同样的道理也适用于政治信仰以及我们在世界上体验威胁的方式。我记得最近火遍全网的一大争议，就是人们听到的究竟是“劳雷尔”（laurel）这个词，还是“雅尼”（yanny）这个词。
this. And I remember one fellow and he smelled it and it just smelled awful to him. And it didn't smell awful to many of the other graduate students. And he was convinced that this was some kind of psychological trick that we were trying to, you know, get him to say, well, yeah, it doesn't smell bad. It was one of those studies. When, in fact, he just couldn't believe that people were that different in the way they smelled this substance. And I think the same thing applies to political beliefs and to the way we experience threats in the world. I remember one of the things that broke the internet recently was the big controversy about whether people heard the word
但这种观点认为，我们看到或听到某事物的方式一定就是其他人看到或听到它的方式，当其他人看到或听到世界的角度不尽相同时，人们就会产生一种彻底难以置信的感觉。是的，这只是我们习惯了。这对我们来说合情合理。所以我确实认为这是我们需要不断强调的事情：我们的神经系统接线确实存在相当大的差异。让我们来看看这在移民问题上是如何体现的。这里是共和党人唐纳德·特朗普。他们带来了毒品，带来了犯罪，他们是强奸犯，而有些人我认为是好人。
laurel or heard the word yanny. But this idea that the way that we see here something must be the way everyone else sees it and there's just this feeling of utter disbelief that other people might not see in here the world the same way. Yeah, it's just what we're used to. It makes sense to us. So I do think that's something we need to continue to pound away on that, that we really are wired up quite differently. Let's look at how this plays out when it comes to the subject of immigration. Here is Republican Donald Trump. They're bringing drugs, they're bringing crime, they're rapists, and some I assume are good people.
这里是民主党人南希·佩洛西。我们不断被来到我们国家的移民所激励。他们的奉献、勇气以及对最初将他们吸引到这里的美国梦的执着，强化了美国梦。现在需要明确说明的是，约翰，完全有可能是政客们在说话。他们确实可能在说一些纯粹出于政治策略的话，但威胁感知方面的差异
And here is Democrat Nancy Pelosi. We are constantly re-indigrated by immigrants coming to our country. Their commitment and courage and commitment to the American dream, which drew them here in the first place, strengthened the American dream. Now it's important to stipulate here, John, that it's entirely possible these are politicians. They might indeed be saying things that are just politically strategic, but how might differences in threat perception
会如何塑造自由派和保守派总体上对移民问题的看法呢？是的，我真的认为移民、国防、警察、法律和秩序，这些才是我们的核心所在，也是政治分歧的核心所在。所以，你知道，如果我是一个像韦恩·拉皮埃尔那样能感受到这些威胁并认为它们无处不在的人，那么在我看来，我就会希望政府提出一套能够帮助减少这些威胁的政策，我该怎么做呢？
shape the way liberals and conservatives in general think about the subject of immigration? Yeah, I really think immigration, defense, police, law, and order, I think this is really at the core of who we are and at the core of political differences. So, you know, if I am a person like Wayne LaPierre who feels these threats and thinks they're all around us, then it seems to me I would want a set of policies
我会通过允许人们武装自己来做到这一点。我会通过在国防上投入巨资来做到这一点。我会通过允许人们武装自己来做到这一点。我会通过在国防上投入巨资来做到这一点。我将赋权警察。我要实行死刑。我不允许移民来这里。或者如果他们来了，将会受到极其严格的背景审查，
put forward by our government that helped to reduce those threats and how am I gonna do this? I'm going to do it by allowing people to be well armed. I'm going to do it by spending a lot on defense. I'm going to do it by allowing people to be well-armed. I'm going to do it by spending a lot on defense. I'm going to empower police. I'm going to have the death penalty. I'm going to not allow immigrants to come here. Or if they do, they're going to be extremely vetted,
正如总统曾经说过的那样。所以，你知道，对于具备威胁敏感心态的人来说，这些都是顺理成章的步骤，他们真的无法理解为什么会有人反对这些事情，因为这能帮我们成为一个更安全的地方。现在，在研究政客们在现实世界中的言论时，存在着各种各样的混杂因素。
as the president once said. So, you know, those, I think, to a threat-sensitive mindset are steps that, you know, they only make sense. They just can't really understand why anybody would be a post of those kinds of things, because this would help us to be a safer place. Now, there are all kinds of confounding factors when it comes to studying how politicians speak in the actual world.
政治考量很难与心理和生物特征区分开来。但约翰和其他人在实验环境中研究了这些差异。约翰曾向自由派和保守派展示积极和消极的图片，他发现他们的反应截然不同。积极的图片类似于美丽的日落、某人在滑雪坡上享受快乐，或者是快乐的孩子。消极的图片则是像被飓风夷为平地的房屋、吃虫子的男人、或是营养不良的儿童。我们把人们连接到一些生理设备上。
Political considerations that are difficult to disentangle from psychological and biological traits. But John and others have studied these differences in experimental settings. John once showed liberals and conservatives positive and negative pictures, and he found they reacted very differently. A positive picture would be something like a beautiful sunset or somebody enjoying themselves on a ski slope, a happy child. A negative picture would be things like a house that had just been leveled by a hurricane, or a guy eating worms, or children who are malnourished. We had people hooked up to some physiological devices.
最明显的是电皮肤活动或皮肤电导，这是观察某人对该刺激是否有反应、是否有生理唤醒的常用方法。我们发现，当人们看到这类图像时确实会有所唤醒，因为它们包含一些情感内容。但我们往往发现，自由派对积极图像的反应更强烈，而保守派对消极图像的反应更强烈。据我所了解，在你进行的一项大脑成像研究中，志愿者们被展示了令人作呕的图片，仅仅通过单张图片的大脑激活情况，就能相当准确地分辨出谁是自由派，谁是保守派。
The most obvious one is electoral-dermal activity or skin conductance, which is a common way of seeing if somebody is just having a reaction, having a physiological arousal to that stimulus. And what we found is that people do have arousals when they see these kinds of images, because they have some emotional content. But we tended to find that liberals were more reactive to the positive images, and conservatives are more reactive to the negative images. I understand that in one brain imaging study that you conducted, volunteers were shown disgusting images, and brain activation from even a single image was actually pretty good
确实如此。已有三四项研究试图探究自由派和保守派的大脑激活模式是否不同。我们所做的研究回溯到了我们最喜欢的方法，即向他们展示这些不同类型的图片。事实上，我们对残肢断臂的图片最感兴趣。你是对的。当我们这样做时，在对他们一无所知的情况下，把人群分类变得非常容易。我们所看的只是脑部扫描结果，
at being able to tell who was liberal and who was conservative. That's true. There have been three or four studies that attempt to see if the brain activation patterns of liberals and conservatives is different. And the one that we did goes back to kind of our favorite thing, which just showed them these these different kinds of pictures. Actually, we had the most luck with pictures of mutilations. And you're right. When we did that, it was very easy to categorize people, you know, without knowing anything about them. All we would look at was the brain scan results. And
并且只需根据这些结果，就能以极其高的准确率判断他们是自由派还是保守派。自由派的大脑在看到残肢断臂的图片时，大脑中一个叫做S2（体感第二区）的区域要活跃得多。如果你遭受疼痛，大脑的这个部分就会被激活。
we could be incredibly accurate knowing whether they're a liberal or without knowing anything about them. All we would look at was the brain scan results. And we could be incredibly accurate knowing whether they're a liberal or conservative just on the basis of that. Liberals brains, when they looked at mutilation images were much more active in a part of the brain called the S2, somatosensory 2. And this is part of the brain that will be activated if you suffer pain.
所以如果我踢你的小腿胫骨，你的体感第二区就会被激活。但当你看到别人痛苦时，它也会被激活。因此，如果你看到有人踩到生锈钉子并直接穿透脚掌的电影，你的体感第二区也会被激活。我们在这些脑部扫描中看到的是，
So if I kick you in the shin, your somatosensory too would be active. But it's also active if you see pain in others. And so if you would see a movie of somebody stepping on a rusty nail, it goes right through their foot. Your somatosensory too would be active. And what we saw in these brain scans
自由派比保守派更有可能激活体感第二区。这并不意味着保守派铁石心肠。这只是意味着当他们看到这些不同的图像时，大脑发生的反应有所不同。现在你可能会辩称，很多这类研究都是相关性的。你也可以辩称，约翰和其他人发现的许多规律
was that liberals were more likely to have activation in somatosensory too than conservatives. Doesn't mean that conservatives are hard-hearted. It just means that things are happening differently when they see these different images. Now you could argue that a lot of this research is correlational. You could also argue that a lot of the patterns
都符合成长经历在塑造政治偏好方面的作用。情况是这样的。假设我在一个保守的家庭中长大。我从父母那里学会了政治上的保守，但我的家庭也影响了我身上与政治毫无关系的方方面面。他们塑造了我喜欢的食物种类、我喜欢看的电影种类、我喜欢的运动种类。
that John and others find are consistent with the power of upbringing in shaping political preferences. Here's how. Let's say I'm raised in shaping political preferences. Here's how. Let's say I'm raised in a conservative home. I learn to be politically conservative from my parents, but my family also influences all kinds of other things about me that have nothing to do with politics. They shape the kind of food I like to eat, the kind of movies I like to watch, the kind of sports I enjoy.
按照这种推理，自由派和保守派在各方面都存在差异，并不是因为生物学。这只是说明了你的家庭环境如何影响你身上的许多方面。有一种非常有趣的方法可以将生物学的影响与环境的影响分离开来。想想同卵双胞胎和异卵双胞胎。同卵双胞胎拥有相同的基因。异卵双胞胎拥有相似但不相同的基因。如果你追踪一组异卵双胞胎和同卵双胞胎，每一对双胞胎都在同一个
By this line of reasoning, the fact that liberals and conservatives are different on all manner of things isn't about biology. It just shows you how your family environment can affect lots of things about you. There's a really interesting way to separate the effects of biology from the environment. Think about fraternal and identical twins. Identical twins have identical genes. Fraternal twins have similar but not identical genes. If you follow a group of fraternal and identical twins, each twin pair is raised in the same
家庭中抚养长大。每一对吃相同的食物，听相同的对话，看相同的电影。现在，如果你发现同卵双胞胎群体和异卵双胞胎群体之间存在差异，这就表明是生物学而非环境在起主导作用。我问约翰，SAT（双胞胎）研究揭示了关于政治偏好的什么信息。我们很幸运能访问到一个数据集。它非常庞大，包含由一个叫林登·埃夫斯的人收集的成千上万对双胞胎的数据。
household. Each pair eats the same food, listens to the same conversations, watches the same movies. Now, if you find differences between identical twins as a group and fraternal twins as a group, that suggests that biology, non-environment, is the driver. I asked John what SAT studies reveal about political preferences. We were fortunate to have access to a data set. It was very large, includes thousands and thousands of twin pairs collected by a guy named Lyndon Eves. A long ago, it's fairly data data set, but it was a valuable one for us because it included
时间很久远了，这是一个相当老的数据集，但对我们来说它很有价值，因为它包含了大量关于他们政治观点的信息。当我们对这些数据应用标准的双胞胎设计方法时，我们确实发现政治观点具有相当高的遗传性。尽管人们经常误解这一点，但我们的结果表明，我们大约30%或40%的政治观点来自于遗传。但这困扰了很多人，这在政治学界是一项相当具争议的研究。许多人对此非常反感。他们往往过度解读这些结果，让人听起来好像我们在说一切都是由基因决定的。但如果是34%由基因决定，那么显然有50%、60%、70%来自于环境。所以我们想说的是，这个基因成分并非零，但显然这已经足以让一些人感到不安了。
lots of information about their political views. And when we subjected these data to the standard twin design approach, we did indeed find that the political views were quite heritable. Although people oftentimes misread this, our results suggested that maybe 30 or 40 percent of our political views come from genetics. But that bothered a lot of people, and this was quite a controversial study in political science. Many people didn't like that at all. And they tended to over-interpret those results and make it sound like we were saying that everything was genetic. But if it's 34% genetic, that obviously is 50, 60, 70% that comes from the environment. So all we're saying is that that genetic component is not zero, but apparently that was enough
所以基本上，你在某种程度上能够看出，同卵双胞胎的政治倾向比异卵双胞胎的政治倾向有更紧密的联系，这告诉你，生物学的某些元素、基因的某些元素正在驱动政治偏好。没错，这话讲得很对。再说一次，把政治观点和其他事物进行比较是很有意思的。例如，当你采用同种研究设计时，身高的遗传率大约是80%，人格特质的遗传率大约是50%到60%，而政治观点，我会说是30%到40%。所有这些工作的一大意义，除了其本身很有趣之外，在于它帮助我们以全新的视角思考我们所经历的政治冲突。你曾提出这样的观点：在许多情况下，当我们越是能够将不同群体之间的差异视为内在的或生物学的时候，在某种程度上，它就会改变我们看待这些差异的方式。约翰，跟我谈谈这个想法。
that some people were upset about that. And so you basically, you're able to tell in some ways that there is a closer link in the political orientation of identical twins, then in the political orientation of fraternal twins, and that tells you that there is some element of the biology, some element of genetics that is driving political preferences. Exactly, now that's well put. And again, it's nice to compare political views with other kinds of things. Height, for example, turns out to be about 80% heritable when you see these, when you subjective the same kind of design, personality traits are about 50% to 60% political views, 30% to 40% I would say. One of the big implications of all of this work, besides just being interesting in and itself, is that it helps us, helps us think think about the political conflicts we have with fresh insight. And you've made the case
好的。当其他特质被理解为具有生物学基础时，我想到了像“惯用手”这样的特征。我们过去认为，如果你是左撇子，那只是因为你养成了偷懒的习惯。
that in many ways the more we're able to see the differences between groups of people as inherent or biological, in some ways it changes the way we think about those differences. Talk to me about that idea, John. Yes. When other traits have been understood to be biological, I'm thinking of something like handiness. We used to think that if you were left handed, that was just because you got into a lazy habit.
我父亲是左撇子，老师——那是很久以前的事了——每当他用左手写字时，就会用尺子打他的手，强迫他用右手写字。所以我们当时把这视为一种缺陷，一种需要根除的东西。当然，现在我们明白了，左撇子具有很强的生物学基础。这比单纯的偷懒习惯要深得多。当然，今天还有一个重大的例子，那就是性取向。当人们意识到性取向确实是由生物学驱动的，而不是他们自己随意决定的事情时，人们对它的容忍度就会高得多。所以我们想知道，政治方面是否也会发生同样的事情。
My father was left handed, and the teacher, this was long ago, would beat him on the hand with a ruler whenever he wrote with his left hand, trained him to write with his right hand. So we viewed that as a flaw, something that need to be driven out. Of course, now we understand that being left handed is very biological. This is something much deeper than just a lazy habit. Or of course, you know, the big one today would be sexual orientation. When people realize that sexual orientation is indeed biologically driven and not something that they just have decided to do, then people are much more tolerant of that. So we were wondering if perhaps the same thing might happen with regard to politics.
如果我们意识到我们的政治对手不仅仅是在偷懒，而是以一种不同的方式来看待世界，也许我们会对他们多一些宽容，因为如果我们至少理解他们的出发点是什么，哪怕我们仍然深切不同意他们的结论，这才是我们能够取得进展的唯一途径。你会对那些批评者说些什么呢？他们认为，将心理特质和生物学差异归咎于我们深层政治冲突的论点是说不通的，因为我们国家过去并没有在自由派和保守派之间产生如此巨大的分歧。曾几何时，我们有更多更多的人处于政治中间派，最自由的共和党人
If we realize that our political opponents were not simply being lazy, but rather, we're oriented to the world in a different fashion, that maybe we would be a little bit more tolerant of them, that this is the only way we're going to get anywhere, if we at least understand where they're coming from, even if we still might deeply disagree with their conclusions. What would you say to critics who would say, the argument that psychological traits and biological differences are beneath our deep political conflicts doesn't make sense, because we didn't always have this deep divide in our country between liberals and conservatives. There was a time when we had many, many more people in the center, the most liberal Republican
往往比最保守的民主党人还要偏左，而且近年来政党确实发生了阵营重组。是什么解释了这种变化，尤其是过去20、30年的变化？我对这种论点的回应是，我相信我们一直都存在着这种相同的分歧。这种最基础的差异存在于两类人之间：一类人对威胁相当敏感，认为我们需要保持警惕；另一类人则更热衷于实验和尝试新事物。拉尔夫·沃尔多·爱默生曾说过一句名言，很抱歉我无法一字不差地背诵出来，但大意是：传统支持者与
was often to the left of the more most conservative Democrat, and there really has been a sorting of the political parties in recent years. What explains this change, especially over the last 20, 30 years? What I would say to that argument is that I believe we have always had this very same division. This very basic difference between people who are fairly sensitive to threats and think we need to be vigilant in those people who are more into experimentation and trying new things. Ralph Waldo Emerson has a great quote, I'm sorry I can't give it to you verbatim, but it's basically that the division between those people who are supporters of tradition
创新支持者之间的分歧由来已久，自创世以来便构建了整个世界。约翰·希宾是内布拉斯加大学林肯分校的政治学教授。他多年来一直致力于研究自由派和保守派在心理和神经学上的差异。与凯文·史密斯和约翰·阿尔弗雷德一起，他是《天生倾向：自由派、保守派与政治分歧的生物学》一书的合著者。约翰，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。
and those people who are supportive of innovation is very old and has structured the world since time began. John Hibbing is a political scientist at the University of Nebraska-Lincoln. He has spent years studying the psychological and neurological differences between liberals and conservatives. Along with Kevin Smith and John Alfred, he's the co-author of the book, predisposed, liberals, conservatives, and the biology of political differences. John, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar.
很高兴能和你在一起。本期《隐藏的大脑》由托马斯·刘制作，塔拉·博伊尔和卡米拉·巴尔加斯·雷斯特波参与剪辑。我们的团队成员包括雷娜·科恩、珍妮·施密特、帕特·沙阿和劳拉·夸雷勒。本周我们默默无闻的英雄是亚历克斯·扬。亚历克斯与NPR的IT团队一起工作。他最近协助我们在整个
It was a pleasure to be with you. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Thomas Liu, and edited by Tara Boyle and Camilla Vargas Restrepo. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah and Laura Quarelle. Our unsung hero this week is Alex Yang. Alex works with our IT team at NPR. He recently helped us update our archiving systems throughout the
过程中更新了存档系统，这是一项涉及100多个《隐藏大脑》剧集的巨大工程。他回答了我们无休止的问题，却没有翻过一次白眼。谢谢你，亚历克斯。你可以在脸书和推特上找到更多关于《隐藏的大脑》的内容。如果你喜欢这个节目，请今天告诉你的一个朋友。再次强调，如果你热爱《隐藏的大脑》，请花一点时间，想想一个朋友，并把这个节目推荐给他们。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。
process and this was a massive undertaking involving more than a hundred hidden brain episodes. He answered all our endless questions without once rolling his eyes. Thank you Alex. You can find more hidden brain on Facebook and Twitter. If you like the show, please tell one friend about us today. Again, if you love Hidden Brain, take one moment, think of one friend, and spread the word. I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集暂时还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。